In this lesson we will cover a brief history of the internet. The internet has
its roots in the ARPA Net which was
conceived in, 1966 to connect big academic computers
together. The first operational ARPA Net nodes
came online, in 1969 at UCLA, SRI, UCSB,
and Utah. Around the same time, the National
Physical Laboratory in the UK also came online.
By 1971, there were about 20 ARPANet Nodes,
and the first host-to-host protocol. There were two
cross country links, and all of the links
were at 50 KBPS. Here is a rough sketch
of the ARPANet as drawn by Larry Roberts in the late 1960s. You can see the four
original Nodes here, as well as some other
well known players, such as Berkeley. The MAC project
at MIT, BBN, Harvard, Carnegie-Mellon, Michigan, Illinois,
Dartmouth, Stanford, and so forth. This is what
the ARPANET looked like in the late 1960s. Here's a picture of the ARPANET in
June 1974. And you can see not
only some additional networks that have come online,
but also a diagram of the machines
that are connected at each of the universities.
You can also see a connection here between
the ArpaNet and MPLnet. Of course, the ArpaNet
wasn't the only network. There were other networks
at the time. Sat Net operated over satellite.
There were packet radio networks and there were
also Ethernet local area network. Work started in
1973 on replacing the original network control protocol
with TCP/IP. Where IP was the Internetwork Protocol and
TCP was the Transmission Control Protocol. TCP/IP
was ultimately standardized from 1978 to 1981
and included in Berkley UNIX in 1981. And on January 1st, 1983 the internet
had one of its flag days, where the arbanet transitioned to TCP IP. Now
the internet continued to grow, but the
number of computers on the internet really didn't
start to take off until the mid 90s.
You can see here that around August 1995 there
were about 10 million hosts on the internet,
and five years later there was an order magnitude
of hosts on the internet. More than 100
million. During this period the Internet experienced a number
of technical milestones. In 1982. The internet saw
the rollout of the domain name system which replaced
the host.txt file containing all the world's
machine names with a distributed name lookup system.
1988 saw the rollout of TCP congestion
control after the net suffered a series of
congestion collapses. 1989 saw the NSF net
and BGP inter-domain routing. Including support for routing
policy. The 90s, on the other hand,
saw a lot of new applications. In approximately
1992, we started to see a lot of streaming media, including audio and video. The
Web was not soon after, in 1993, which allowed users to browse a mesh of
hyperlinks. The first major search engine was Altavista, which came online
in December of 1995, and peer to peer protocols and applications
including file sharing, began to emerge around 2000.